welcome back to Facebook so Barbie has
long been criticized by feminists as a
symbol of unattainable princess-like
perfection the iconic metal doll is now
the inspiration for a Hollywood movie
one of the most anticipated of the
entire year capping Barbie's Evolution
from symbol of the patriarchy to
feminist icon
[Music]
dates with can club meetings tennis
know how big the brain is
Sophia it is Mia medium what's going on
why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
so Fantastic Plastic feminist icon all
sexiest claptrap with the movies
outrageously dismissive tagline she is
everything he is just Ken as Barbie
actually done a full 180 is she now anti
not just Ken but man well I'm joined by
talk TV uh contributor Esther cracker
and also by talk to V presenter Rosanna
Lockwood and also drum roll back from
the world's longest holiday bye Grace
Blakely our socialist commentator I love
calling you that welcome back welcome
back
we've almost missed you I have missed
you very much as well obviously and
you're wearing your Barbie outfit I have
apparently been talking
you did this on purpose I mean yes
you did this to seduce that is a massive
compliment honestly if I look anything
like Margot Robbie I will take that so
look let's start with with you then on
this giving you come dressed as Barbie
so there are a number of Barbie
characters in the movie right one plays
President Barbie one plays Dr Barbie one
plays a Barbie with a Nobel Prize in
physics one is a mermaid Barbie however
all the male characters in Barbie world
are simply called Ken so it's pretty
clear where this movie is going this is
an assault on not just Ken but all men I
mean I think men in general will have to
be a bit kind of snowflakey suggest
they're being assaulted by a Barbie
movie but I kind of think that's besides
the point I mean I think you know the
the question that we have around this
one whether or not Barbie is a feminist
icon actually well I think it matters
less than the fact that the Barbie
franchise has commercialized the
feminist critique so now you can be like
oh you can feel like a good feminist
because you buy a doll for 25.99 or you
can feel like a hashtag girl boss
because Barbie has a Nobel Prize or
Barbie's an entrepreneur whereas
actually feminism is rooted in the
struggles of ordinary women it's about
the fact that you know women often get
paid less it's about the fact that women
are on the front line of some of the
hardest sectors to work in in care what
in um in our Healthcare System and
social care it's about the fact they do
so much unpaid
laborers do you know I mean okay great
questions
have you ever met a female Brickler I
don't know no you haven't but I love the
assumption that being a bricklayer is
harder than like caring for the terminal
ill and dying have you ever been a
Bricker in the winter but like have you
ever been somewhere yes I actually have
yeah
very very challenging job isn't it and
like not as hard as being a bricklayer
in what sense
physically challenging emotionally
challenging I mean they're a care
workers who are running up and down
between houses getting paid less than
minimum wage I get that but you don't
you don't make a fortune as a bricklayer
either and you're out in in the element
I just don't understand
each other it's a bizarre culture let me
try and get one single word in here um
so Rosanna look Barbies jobs include
being an astronaut a surgeon Olympic
Athlete downhill skier aerobics
instructor TV news reporter vet Rockstar
doctor army officer Air Force pilot
Summit Diplomat rap musician
presidential candidate baseball player
scuba diver lifeguard firefighter
engineer dentist and many more I mean
she's not a bad feminist icon she's done
everything she's had over 200 careers
apparently since she was first conceived
but you know is she a feminist icon look
when you said unattainable princess
perfect like Perfection this is what you
were thinking of these three women here
I think all three of us Perfectly
Imperfect can we settle on that
we probably all played with Barbies
going off I'm gonna guess that given
Barbie's enormous reach now given how
many different Barbie dolls are there
you can almost have a Barbie doll for
any type whatever is she legitimately a
feminist icon no I don't think she is
but there are other toys available if
you don't like her
to be a feminist icon why can't girls
just play with pretty dolls
I've never done anything to do with
feminism I don't think that feminism
should be co-opted by Massive
multinational corporations well that's
fine but I don't think
but Grace what about if it's shaping the
way young girls are growing up that's
well I mean I think this is the problem
people have with feminism this is why we
end up having all these debates about
like oh you know
um feminism doesn't account for the
struggles of ordinary people and it's
just like very rich and wealthy women at
the top of companies saying I want more
money it's because feminism which is
actually a critique of capitalism in
part has been taken over by big monster
corporations to basically say look we
have three women on our board so the
gender struggle is over and it's just
this is a symptom of a wider problem all
right you mentioned gender the bank of
England says anyone can get pregnant of
any gender identity
uh they've offered to help pay uh help
staff to pay the gender reassignment
treatment including now this has all
been going on in your absence
ad nauseam some might think this whole
gender debate but this concept that
anyone of any gender identity can become
pregnant is obviously ludicrous I mean
I'm going to start before even opening
up into this discussion talking about
yes I've been away for nine months and
I've come back and watched how our
entire political debate has become
dominated by this tiny tiny Fringe issue
we have this massive moral panic over an
issue that affects so few people not a
friendship the climate is literally like
the Earth is
a massive cost of living prices going on
I was honestly just shocked that this is
what we're doing you can care about the
climate and you can also care about the
full frontal attack on the Integrity of
women's sport because of transgender
athletes you can care about men rapists
being put into female prisons that cause
Nicola sturgeon her job by the way you
can care about all those issues too and
yet I would have thought you would have
come back and gone you know what I've
seen the light Biz you're right about
this and yet this is what we're talking
about I think there is a reason why we
are talking about this issue rather than
the bank of England just raised interest
rates that's going to mean that millions
of families are not going to be able to
repay their debt repay their loans they
can be pushed into poverty and here we
are talking about some you know I think
you've just hit the nail on the head
because shouldn't the bank of England be
more concerned with bringing down
inflation rates than you know offering
the ability
I'm sure this was just some sort of
random thing
or economics experts if you look at the
Crux of the issue this was actually
probably a freedom of information
request Stonewall uh the bank of England
applied to Stonewall to say we want to
be in your top 100 list of diversity and
inclusion sort of index thing this was
last year they made this application the
information has only been revealed now
and I would say that that is the
Telegraph and the other papers
capitalizing on the argument that the
bank of England says lacks monetary
policy and they're trying to make the
argument that they've been too focused
on diversity playing up to cult but
let's be clear
but you can have a hundred and twenty
thousand genders as many as you like
only women can and get pregnant but like
I mean that's just a biological fact
only women get pregnant people you can
have as many gender debates as you want
you can feel like a mouse for all I
guess but you can't actually pretend
anyone but other than the biological
female can have a baby sure only people
who are born women can get pregnant
people who are born women can also
become men
can also legitimately become mothers
biological men are biological men yeah I
mean if they can be more women they can
be a trans man that's something on that
why do we have to change it I mean I
agree I made this point to you like
years ago and I thought we kind of
settled it you know you have CIS women
and trans women and CIS men and trans
men we don't have to get all up in arms
about all this stuff it just doesn't
matter that much I'm so glad you do
still get up in arms about
I really missed this uh Esther I mean I
agree with you the bank of England get
on with fixing yeah the economic crisis
is the Optics of this that's even more
frustrating because you don't want a
news story of the bank of England you
know paying for their employees gender
transitioning when they're clearly
bigger issues at hand here
um but I I think it's just this
obsession with companies that feel like
they have to you know talk about these
issues all the time I'm just happy for
business to function as a business I
don't get to know their stance on gender
identity or anything like that okay I
actually agree well that's in itself a
shocking moment do any of you have a
view about Johnny bestow and the way he
was out at Lords
this my dad showed me this was the clip
where did that say my dad said that that
it was slightly unfair to have knocked
him out and that there should have been
um what did he say that it should have
been reviewed or something and the
ordinarily that that's what would have
happened because there was something
your dad's right okay no idea no view no
view yeah
it's great to have you back really I
nearly almost enjoyed that statement
it's been great I really missed you